Trump is terrible at a ton of things as
I said earlier he is good at making fun
of people that's the reality he's good
at nicknaming people he's good at
stigmatizing people and when you are
potentially going to be fighting someone
as uncharismatic and seemingly unable to
handle your style of attack as Ron
DeSantis one of the best things you can
do is nickname him with something that
will really titillate and scintillate
and hope that he is unable to respond in
kind now the problem with Des
sanctimonious is I don't think a lot of
Republican voters necessarily know what
it means
and of course it is actually accurate
which is when your sanctimonious you
make a show out of being or appearing
morally Superior to others
Ron DeSantis does do that